is going on y'all their advice is that I
go on vocal rest for six weeks so that's
what I'm gonna do
I hate it
but I love you guys Morgan wallen's
latest health update means bad news for
his fans
[Music]
I get to go play the music too I'm
really excited the country star
postponing six weeks of concert dates
I'll see you soon after pulling out of a
concert two weeks ago he was back on
stage last week
say I'm 100 but
yeah I know you've been worried about me
now Morgan appearing tired and emotional
takes to social media I'm gonna go ahead
and get straight to it revealing his
comeback may be came too soon so I went
in and got scoped yesterday and they
told me that I re-injured my vocal cords
and that I have vocal fold trauma music
has always spoke to me in a in a
different way than anything else you
know they told me that if I do this the
right way but I'll get back to 100
percent
and they also said that if I don't
listen and I keep singing then I'll
permanently damage my voice
so for the longevity of my career
this is just the choice I had to make I
don't know what to expect you know in
the future I think it seems like things
are continuing to grow but as of right
now I feel pretty good what else Morgan
was set to perform at the ACM Awards on
Thursday not anymore the singer also has
four nominations including Entertainer
of the Year
[Music]
this comes as Morgan's latest album one
thing at a time tops the charts for its
ninth consecutive week album number
three is finally here how does it feel
it feels different you know just because
I'm different I'm in a different place
in my life than I was in the last one so
um I'm really proud of it
and for now it's the only music his fan
should expect to hear in the future
doctor's orders we're working on
rescheduling all the dates during this
time frame
we've almost got that done but some of
them are pending so I'll keep you
updated I won't be able to make these
festivals that I have during this time
frame but we are going to make those
right in next year music has always
communicated to me in in the strongest
way possible and that's no different
with this you know in in every aspect of
my life the music has always been some
sort of healing I do care about what
people think of me out you know I want
to be viewed as a as a good man
um I truly I try to be you know so I
just want that to to be known I'm just
doing the best I can I hate it
but I love you guys
and I said I appreciate all the support
that you always give me
and
I'll see you soon and I'll be back
better than ever God bless you
foreign
[Music]